مشاهدينا العوده الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
التي سجلت فصلا جديدا من الدعم العسكريه
الغربيه تمثل في تزويد اكياس لاول مره
بدبابات وعربات ثقيله بعد ان ظلت شهورا
تلح في طلب ذلك دون جدوى اعلنت فرنسا انها
ستسلم اوكرانيا دبابات خفيفه من طراز اي
ام اكس 10 ار سي وهي مركبات قتال مدرعه
بدا تصنيعها في ثمانيات القرن الماضي
ويبلغ وزنها نحو 25 طنا ومزوده بمدفع من
عيار 100 واا خمسه
لكنها فرنسا لم توافق بعد على تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات
لوكلارك الاكثر تطورا ونجاعتا وهي مركبه
فرنسيه ثقيله يبلغ وزن الواحده منها 56
طنا ويصل مدى مدفعها الى اربعه كلمترات
كما تطلب قياس من المانيا تزويدها بدبابات
ليوبارد
اثنين هذه الدبابات ذات القدره القتاليه
العاليه فهي مزوده بمنظومه رؤيا وتسديده
تعمل ليلا ونهارا وتستطيع عبور الانهار
والقتال في مختلف الظروف المناخيه اما
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده تدرس
احتمال ارسال مركبات برادلي القتاليه الى
اوكرانيا وهي عربات قتال مدرعه ومزوده
بمدفع عن رشاش وتعتبر من الاليات الاساسيه
في الجيش الامريكي منذ منتصف 800 من
الاسلحه الامريكيه ايضا تطلب القياده
الاوكرانيه تزويدها بدبابات ابرامز وهي
دبابات قتال رئيسيه من الجيل الثالث تزن
نحو 63 طنا ومسلحه بمدفع عيار 120
ملليمترا رشا
سلاح الدبابات تزداد فاعليه في الساحه
الاوكرانيه بغياب سلاح الجو الروسي شبه
الكامل عن الاجواء ويشهد تاريخ الحروب
الحديثه على ادوار استثنائيه قامت بها
الدبابات في ساحات وتواريخ مختلفه
دبابات لاول مره في التاريخ عام
1916 خلال ما تعرف بمعركه الصوم في الحرب
العالميه الاولى بين القوات الالمانيه
وقوات الحلفاء واستخدمت فيها دبابات من
طراز 7 في الالمانيه ودبابات مارك الرابع
البريطاليه اما اكبر معارك الدبابات
واشهرها في التاريخ فكانت معركه كورس بين
القوات الالمانيه والقوات الصوفيه خلال
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وقد دارت قرب
مدينه كورس جنوب غرب موسكو بين ثمانيه
وخمسين دبابه سوديتيه
250 دبابه المانيه واستمرت من الخامس من
يوليو حتى الثالث والعشرين من اغسطس عام
1943 وقد حددت مسار الحرب في النصف الثاني
من القرن العشرين تعتبر همم حرب اكتوبر
عام 73 من اكبر الحروب التي شاركت فيها
الدبابات حيث استخدمت مصر والجيوش العربيه
واسرائيل اكثر من اثنين 10,000
دبابه ومدرعه دمر نحو
الفين,600 منها خلال الحرب
مشاهدينا قبل الحوار مع الخبير العسكري
بشان المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا
نذكر بالبيان
الامريكيه المشترك الذي
قال هذا البيان ان كل من الرئيس جوبيدن
والمستشر
في اتصال هاتفي على ضروره الاستمرار في
تقديم الدعم المالي والانساني والعسكري
والدبلوماسيه لاوكرانيا في هذا البيان
هناك ذكر لمجموعه من المساعدات لا سيما
منها المدرعات وبطاريات صواريخ الدفاع
الجوي سنطلع على تفاصيلها مع مراسله
الجزيره في البيت الابيض وجد واقفي وجد
اليك الكلب
نعم حسن طبعا هذا البيان المشترك الذي صدر
عن البيت الابيض
يؤكد في الرئيس الامريكي وكذلك المستشار
الالماني استمرار دعم بلديه مال لاوكرانيا
في مواجهه مواصفه البيان
حرب العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا طبعا في
هذه في هذا البيان ورد بان الولايات
المتحده سترسل المره الاولى مركبات برادلي
القتاليه وهي تستخدم لسنوات من قبل الجيش
الامريكي هذه المركبات القتاليه مزوده
بالواحده منها برشاش وكذلك بالصاروخ مضاد
للدبابات وهي قادره على حمل 10 من الجنود
او من العناصر القتاليه الى ساحه المعركه
او منها وهي قادره على القيام بمهام
دفاعيه وهجوميه في ان طبعا هذا من قبل من
احد مطالب الرئيس همم
الاوكرانيزلنسكي عندما قدمه هنا الى
واشنطن الشهر الماضي وهو تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات ومركبات قتاليه لنقل الجنود
استعدادا لفصل الربيع الذي يتوقع ان تكون
المعارك ان تشتد المعارك خلال حسن طبعا
المانيا من جانبها تعهدت بتسليم اوكرانيا
نسخه مماثله النسخه الالمانيه المماثله
لهذه العربات القتاليه التي تستخدم ايضا
من قبل عناصر المشات لنقل المقاتلين من
والى خطوط الجبهات خلال المعارك وهكذلك
الجديد ايضا بان المانيا يتعهدت بالمثل
مثل الولايات المتحده وتعهد الامريكي
الشهر الماضي بتسليم اوكرانيا بطاريه
باتريوت الدفاعيه همم المانيا اليوم تعهدت
بتسليم همم اوكرانيا يا بطاريه ايضا بحسب
ما ورد في بيان البيت الابيض طبعا عندما
جاء زولنسكي كان مطلبه من قبل الرئيس
الامريكي وهو التواصل مع القاده
الاوروبيين من اجل الضغط باتجاه تزويد
اوكرانيا اسلحه متطوره
وليس اسلحه قديمه من الحقبه السوفيتيه
وواضح من خلال الاعلان الامريكي الالماني
المشترك ان الامور تسير بهذا الاتجاه حسن
رئيسيتان نوعيه هذه الاسلحه مازلنا عمليه
نتحدث عن كم كبير من الاسلحه لكن
تعتبر اسلحه دفاعيه اكثر منها
هجوميه باستثناء بعض همم الدبابات التي
يمكن استخدامها هجوميا لكن ما زال الاطار
المحدد من البيت الابيض ومن الاوروبيين
همم ما زال نفسه على ما نفهم
نعم وبالتحديد ربما الحديث عن ابرامز حتى
اليوم الولايات المتحده ترفض تسليم هذه
الدبابات لاوكرانيا ولكن
حسن الولايات المتحده تؤكد اكثر من مره
تحديدا البيت الابيض بان طبيعه المساعدات
الامنيه التي تقدمها لاوكرانيا تعتمد على
طبيعه الارض القتال كيفيه
تغير او تحول شكل العمليات القتاليه على
الارض وبناء عليها تجري تقيما
للاسلحه التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا في الفتره
المقبله حاليا في هذه الفتره في الشتاء
ترى الولايات المتحده ان اوكرانيا بحاجه
التي ارسلتها خلال الشهر الماضي هذه
البيتروت حاليا يتدرب عليها الجنود
الامريكيون وكذلك بحاجه الى هذا النوع من
العربات القتال الذي ايضا سوف يتلقى
الجنود الاوكرانيون تدريبا عليه
الجزيره من البيت الابيض
وينضم الينا من جنود العقيده الكسندر
فوتير رئيسا لتحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه صيد الكسندر مرحبا بك
واضح ان هذه
المعدات التي اعلن عنها البيان الامريكي
الالماني انما هي تحضيرا لمعركه الربيع
يعني عندما
تتغير ظروف المناخ والاجواء هل يمكن ان
تغير شيئا في ارض المعارك
قصه
يؤثر على الوضع العسكري لان نوعيه ونوع
هذه المعدات التي وعد بتزويدها لاوكرانيا
ستغير قواعد اللعبه طبعا هي هي ليست اخر
ما توصل اليه التكنولوجيا في ترسانه
لكنها حديثه ومؤثره والسبب في ارسالها الى
اوكرانيا الان بسيطه حقيقه حلف النايته لم
يعد لديه ايه ذخائر من التي تتماشى مع
انظمه
واصلحت حلف وارسو لهذا السبب الجيش
الاوكراني بدا يتحول الى معايير ومعدات
النيته طيب وهذه نقطه سلبيه ام ايجابيه
الكويت
ايجابيا بسبب المعايير الجوده
هذه المعدات التي يمكن ان تستخدم بناء على
الوعود التي قدمت ستكون سيكون تاثيرها
اكبر بكثير مما كان مستخدم في المعركه حتى
الان ثانيا هذا سيسمح لاكرانيا بان لا
تتسلى موعد ذات من فرنسا وامريكا فقط بل
من اي بلد ينتج معدات تتماشى ومعايير
اسلحه الفنيته همم
اذا اذا اردنا ان نسال همم لعلك اطلعت على
مضمون هذا البيان ونوعيه الاسلحه
والمركبات والدبابات اي اي منها هي ال-
ال- الاكثر تاثيرا في مسار المعارك او
يتوقع ان يكون لها الاثر الاكبر في مسار
المعارك على الارض لاحقا
والتي هي ذات اهميه بالغه في ارض المعركه
اليوم وهما وحدات القياس التي تقيس القوه
الناريه واثارها في الميدان ثانيا الوحدات
المدفعيه
والدبابات لكل انواع من انواع الخفيفه الى
انواع الثقيله وهي كلها موعوده ضمن قائمه
المعدات اذا سنرى حرفيا مئات من مئات من
قطع على المدفعيه والتي يتم اخراجها من
الخدمه من بلدان فرنسا وغيرها وترسل
لفائده اوكرانيا
السويسريه حدثنا من جنات